[Music]
we're going to bunk next bunk i want you
to deep dim what are you doing today
buddy i'm doing well
yeah so why why i value the principle of
life as you were defining it well you
you clearly do i guess is what i would
say you want i would assign value of
life at the point of a conscious
experience a sentient experience to be
more specific so should we be able to
kill people in a coma
should we be able to kill people in a
comatose state no because they would
have stated that um given their given
preferences before the komodo state and
then we ought preserve those from when
they wake up from the comatose state
that seems like an unworkable system
what if we don't know that they're going
to wake up from their comatose state
well it's kind of hard to say that we
just don't know like obviously it's very
easy there are plenty of people where we
don't know if they're going to recover
from their comas that happens often i'm
sure there are people who we don't know
we're going to recover from their comas
i think that we ought to hear on the
side of life in that situation
but that's because there was previously
stated preference right so their
preference is all that matters so if
before they go into the coma they say
you know
let's say they had a bad day at work and
they come over and say gosh i don't know
if i want to be on this world anymore
and then they go into their coma then
you think we should honor honor their
preference and kill them actually we
have things within the united states of
america to allow people to die it's
called dnr do not resuscitate order and
that states that they don't want to be
brought back to life and i think we all
respect that preference yes so you so
what what you're saying is rather than
merely debating the issue of of abortion
being
bad at all or certainly being worse than
slavery you're you're advocating for the
goodness of assisted suicide
um i think that these two things
definitely do play uh into each other
right so the idea that we ought to
preserve um something that has yet to
come into existence right the conscious
experience of the conscious preferences
of a baby but but i'm not i'm not
suggesting i want to i want to correct
your premise
i just want to correct your premise
before you get too far down the road
then we'll get right back to what i was
saying sure so what what you're saying
is if you want to preserve consciousness
but i'm not saying that i am concerned
primarily with preserving consciousness
i'm saying i'm interested with
preserving life and not ending a life
whether the life is conscious whether
the life is a an adult or who has
expressed preferences or a teenager who
expresses preferences perhaps with less
credibility or a child who has not
reached the age of reason and cannot
actually consent to do anything at all
or a toddler or a baby in the womb so
i'm suggesting something more
fundamental than consciousness
over the past 90 days how often did you
eat a little too much drink a little too
much spend a little too much time in the
office how many times did you ignore
your wife children or friends just to
thumb through social media watch netflix
youtube or a game how many hours did you
waste doom scrolling through headlines
so many men today are distracted they
were dependent on the comforts of this
world making them incapable of even
knowing that they're not free to say no
to those things we were made for more
than this if you desire freedom from
those attachments if you desire true
freedom not the freedom to pursue your
appetites like an animal but the freedom
to be a better husband freedom to be a
better father freedom to be a better man
for others i would invite you to check
out exodus 90. go to exodus 90.com
michael exodus 90 is a 90-day program
that gets us back to the fundamentals of
the faith prayer self-denial and
fraternity more than 50 000 men from
around the world catholics protestants
even people who don't align with the
christian faith have done this of these
men 99 report experiencing greater
freedom you can check it out for
yourself at exodus 90.com
michael that is exodus nine zero dot com
slash michael what i'm trying to get at
then is that we don't seem to value um
things that will never have
consciousness ever again in the same way
that we do value things that will have a
conscious experience or have asserted
conscious preferences that will have
them again would you agree with that
statement i i agree that we yeah we tend
to uh regard conscious beings more than
we regard uh unconscious beings i think
frankly i think that's a little bit part
of the problem
do you think that we should value things
that have not do not have consciousness
that will never have consciousness again
do you think we should value them the
same that we do a human being i'd have
to know what you do you mean someone who
is brain dead well i think we should
value that right we should value them
but i think it's i think we should value
them but it's perfectly fine to remove
their extraordinary medical care because
they're they're not alive by by any real
definition of life but that of course
does not describe
that sounds really wrong that sounds
really morally wrong no they're they're
already dead is what you're saying if
you're talking about brain death you're
talking about someone who's already dead
so i think we kind of circled back on
this but but i guess before before i let
you go i just i guess is there any way
that this relates to an unborn baby to
the question of slavery
the question that we're having right now
is do you value the potentiality of
conscious experience would you value
that i value i value the potential of
all life including conscious experience
because this is a much more interesting
branch of conversation because i can't
gladly
straight to hypothetical right i think
these conversations are very interesting
i love doing them right they're my
favorite thing in the world actually um
i love discussing ideas it seems like
you do too which is actually really
great um
but the point that i'm getting at is
that if you think do you think we can
assign uh moral value to something that
is potential this is not existed yet
okay we gotta go we gotta move on uh i'm
sorry that we didn't touch on the topic
at hand but i i enjoyed our interaction
yeah i enjoyed interacting too did have
a nice
[Music]
you